[Music]
hacking
and [ __ ] and he like disappeared for 10
seconds he was like
i just went quiet sean was like sir
it's pretty epic dude when our president
is the uh
super spreader in chief but that's but
you know
you all heard about enough about that i
gotta be honest with you i'm i'm
the news is so overwhelming and i'm so
glued i can't look away i don't know i
can't look away but i'm starting to feel
like i have to force myself to look away
because i just can't yeah it's
disturbing it's overwhelming
the dude i mean the dude is positive for
covid and he's like
he's positive and he's going
to a rally or some [ __ ] this week on
saturday he's pi
he has covet i love it he has he's
positive
you understand okay do you understand
what i'm saying he has covet
he's positive i shouldn't go to a rally
you know how much i freaked out when i
heard that i that
someone we were near had covered
that's the appropriate response like so
it was like
life flashing before me okay uh gonna
have to quarantine what's gonna happen
theodore what's happening to work what's
gonna happen to this
yeah that's the appropriate response
yeah but he's positive
that's like our one of our employees has
had covet that's like if he's like i'm
gonna come into work
it's fine i feel fine it's a crazy world
and you know
you gotta love i do like it
he got some crazy experimental drugs
apparently the dose alone
it's only been served to 20 different
people it's so experimental and rare
and it costs 1.5 million dollars per
dose
what it's some crazy cocktail and it has
like stem cells in it
which by the way all all of the
republican party is
opposed to so he's like yo give me those
stem cells
when he's dying yeah
[ __ ] out dude anyway so crazy okay
okay anyway i don't get into that it's
just hard not to talk about because you
know
yeah and then the the car
the um derrick chauvin
you was released on bond right oh they
got a dollar
[ __ ] killed yeah yeah there's just so
much
going on yeah he's out there he probably
called it positive too it'll be at the
trump rally
it's like a death people always say that
it's like a death call i mean jesus
christ
anyway listen right thank you everybody
for
being here h3 podcast
is live thank you to our beautiful
members for making this episode possible
we love you appreciate you so much
what a big pimp peace and love peace
that jack is sick wrangler is that
vintage yeah
nice i was so proud proud of that fine
where'd you buy it
etsy oh really where i buy like half of
what i wear
oh it's really nice
so what's going on how are you
i feel just kind of what we just said
i'm just trying not to think of the news
because it's too crazy
to handle but otherwise i'm fine
okay interesting update in our lives
as you know this is this is taking so
long to make that i don't even know if
it's funny anymore irrelevant
but back back back in the day you guys
probably all remember gwyneth paltrow
made a candle that smells like her
vagina
yeah and i'm like dude you know what
[ __ ] that
is she's gonna make a candle that smells
like her vagina i'm gonna make a candle
that smells like my butthole and this
has been in the works for
god how long dan like uh four
months five months something like that
well it's finally coming to fruition
here we have the
sample it won't be ready for a couple of
months we had some kind of delay
whatever who cares it says ethan klein
this smells like my butthole beauty
perfume or perfume or whatever in french
you open it up this was a very
specifically designed scent
i want you to know i think that's like
one of my favorite songs right now eat
up my ass
yeah now this is a very specific
kitchen it is i always say that
oh god i already smell it
yeah did you ever put your nose in there
i did because
we oh
[Laughter]
we weren't sure if this came with the
smell without it we can't wait
trying to solve these things so here's
the thing
it would be easy to just put sulfur in
it have it smell like farts
but we work with the scent company and
we said
this is not meant to smell like farts
that's amateur hour
[ __ ] i want a candle that smells
like my butthole
musty musky you know like hairy
kind of uh it kind of reminds me like
when you go into the bathroom after
someone else pooped in there
great but it i think they nailed it
actually because
it feels it smells like used socks plus
someone else's like like it's not yours
it's someone else
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's not familiar at
all that's the worst right
and so so they really nailed it i mean
it's
really oh on the back on the bottom here
it says
a witty stunning sexually and suggestive
unexpected scent to put you in a mood of
enchantment seduction and passionate
warmth
that's exactly what hers said no it's
not
no it's it's different enough that we
won't get sued is what it is oh
it's just copy i doubt that we rewarded
it a little bit but it's very similar to
what her said
so we are we are donating all the
proceeds to
prostate a prostate uh cancer
charity that's nice yeah so
so i don't know who's gonna buy it
they're pretty expensive to make
let's let's light it oh but take a step
why me first what about you i just been
smelling it all day dude
and the thing is like you guys wash your
hands so vigorously to get rid of the
smell
every time you point it at me i smell it
put your nose right in it's like a gun
that's bad it's so bad it's disgusting
it's but it's so good that's exactly
what i wanted
like they really nailed it it's amazing
like hers didn't smell like a vagina
let's be honest
but she's like that's where my vagina is
well i'll be honest with you that's what
my butthole smells like
hers smelled really good actually we
burned the whole thing in the office
it was very pleasant by the way shout
out to liam this all came about in a
kind of a similar way to aien
yeah where it was a fan this guy named
liam reached out to me when we were
talking about
making a candle and he works for a scent
company a aroma prime
i think is the name and he was like hey
if you really want to do this
we can hook you up so we did it here we
are
oh god do you smell it i don't smell it
yet what's wrong with your nose
well it's probably go it's probably
wafting it's coming straight into me
what did i do i just want to know can
you see the candle in the shot dan
okay good good let's just see how long
we can endure it
it's gonna [ __ ] just this whole
basement
oh i'm jealous i haven't smelled it yet
i don't i want to say is anyone going to
buy this
i know it's a good cause it's foreign
it's a good
gag how much is it gonna be like it's
cost like 30 bucks to make so
i think we were gonna sell it for 75
that's what that's what gwen has sold it
for oh we're gonna do like
the same exact everything we didn't get
a lot of them so hopefully
very limited edition i can't be sitting
on a [ __ ] bunch of inventory
smelling like my butthole imagine just
donating it to goodwill or something
right now they're like what is wrong
with this candle
it's expired so is anyone can i count
anybody
in can i count anybody in for 75
contribution
are going to be going to prostate cancer
awareness i mean i see people just
giving us
money just for the hell of it can i get
it i like that someone is saying i can
smell it
can i get some commitments right now
in chat
sister stank sister snatch
anyway it smells like sister's snatching
yeah there's a couple of yeses
okay we need 250 yeses
[Laughter]
so i'm buying them for sure
i just watched a really quick show
seeing a lot of no ways as well
well look if you're if you're you know
not comfortable 75
is a lot to waste on a gag right
and let's be honest you can't even
really use it i mean you could buy a
nice hoodie for that
i'm seeing lots of yeses but and knows
oh this is i'm thinking like me over
here at the table
you can't handle it
get that the [ __ ] away are you serious
dude you just can't wow my sister
schnapped
[Laughter]
so when you when you light it don't ever
don't ever turn it off
dude anyway real quick the splatter
paint hoodie that i'm wearing right now
we got that really cool really beautiful
oh we got a couple of backpacks new and
improved
vote now t-shirt yada yada yada bob's
your uncle tate fresh stuff you guys got
backpacks
yeah that's cool okay look at this i've
been on tick tock
as you guys know i'm very prolific there
rising star
uh ethan klein h3 uh 150
000 followers no big deal
ela's been active on tick tock too i
just posted one
you're doing good um yeah i
am i started drawing on this hoodie
we'll see when i finish it i want to
keep going like
fill the whole thing and then
i might sell it on teddy fresh i don't
know
it's like a one-off yeah um so what we
have here
is something called it's
[Music]
so apparently this just showed up on my
feet and it was the weirdest thing i i
ever saw in my life
okay what is going on so apparently
there's a huge
jadeite uh
mine and people just
come
it's crazy dude they're just looking for
stones
and then they go on the way out they
it's like a precious stone but what is
jadai used for why are they so is it
well i looked it up because i was kind
of curious
if it's like valuable in electronics or
something as far as i could tell no
it's not it's just jewelry it's a
pressure it's a precious stone
i think you can get jade out of it
so look at this wait that looked like it
was china
wait they're all is this a different
video
yeah these are there's a bunch of these
there's a whole trend of jadeite
these are all different videos wow but
so they they dig up these
vast holes and then all these people
come in to try to find jadeite stones
but is it
like who's um are they allowed to do
that or they're i think
i think well at first i was like why are
they allowing them here it seems
dangerous and weird
but then i think i realize that they're
using them as free labor
because they get the jade stones and
then they sell them on the way out
i guess if it's kind of like if you just
get lucky and you find one
you can sell it to the company that's
letting you be there and yeah like a
grip of cash real quick you're running
away from your candle
hey who wants to get my smells like my
[ __ ] candle 75 dollars
that's a great one help support uh
prostate cancer
there's someone in the chat that's
working with refugee children from
myanmar whoa whoa whoa do they know
about this i'd love to talk with them
yeah
ray bro i've got to learn more about
this
can we get ray on call
oh this guy got a badass stone and
everyone's trying to [ __ ]
take it from him
apparently these people can like strike
it kind of rich right when you find a
good stone
this reminds me of willy wonka when he
found the golden ticket you know run
straight home charlie
[Laughter]
someone in the chat said they're all
running from ethan's candle dude we
literally just said that joe
oh did you i'm sorry
what the [ __ ] bro even at night they're
out here
it's crazy even at night these
[ __ ] are out here
times must be hard and my myanmar man
yeah i mean lightly i'd probably
be out there if i had nothing else to do
that's like desperation dude that's not
fun times
you be out there mining jadeite i mean
instead of like waiting tables
probably i don't think those tables the
way it did
it's like how many people are out there
it's kind of epic i don't know exciting
what that's what it looks like
why does it look like foil
so they have these oh my god so they
have these tools
you'll find out um
they have these tools that they zap it
with the rocks
here like look and they can tell much
jadeites in it
so he's like yeah i'll give you like 10
bucks he's like suck dick
[Music]
so like here they dumping a huge load
and it's just a free-for-all
apparently like people i i was reading
in one of the comments that like
hundreds of people die you know there's
there's
it's just super dangerous
i wonder what are these tools they're
just banging rock
you know what i mean like how's that
helpful
dude these are hard times dude
but when you find one it's like yeah but
if you don't find when you starve
[Music]
i have a feeling it's not that much
money either probably getting
isn't this crazy i'm like absolutely
captivated by this
i love it yeah i mean this is
i don't know why it just makes me want
to do it too i guess you're not getting
that feeling but no i'm getting feeling
of desperation
i want to find one i don't know you want
to find a jadeite rock
yeah i couldn't hide one in the house
for you how much is jadeite look it up
on like uh etsy or some [ __ ]
i like it
i like it but like of all the places to
discover this tick tock you know what i
mean
it's just it's crazy whoa what
apparently it's worth a ton really so
they said jadeite price
per and then google suggested carrot i
guess is how it's measured
let me pull those up comes at a hefty
price of three million dollars per carat
whoa so so
maybe you're right and maybe it's just
like they can actually make so much
money
yeah it's so beautiful by the way
jadeite like look at this it's gorgeous
tell you i want to go find some jedi
so this is what they're after huh
man have you seen like this ancient
chinese dynasty
[ __ ] that's like they have all these
bowls and stuff made out of jade it's
like
so sick um jadeite
price
hmm i can't tell if they're yeah three
million per carrot [ __ ] me
how much is a carrot that doesn't seem
like that much one carrot
jadeite uh necklace
one carrot seems small doesn't it
looks pretty big to me that's one carrot
that's a lot
that's the decent decent chunk yeah i
did
so yeah i can't tell if it's a
desperation thing or if they're just
trying to get rich
so i don't and then there's this where
it's all wrapped up in yellow and
i i don't get it
i don't know
what is he do i don't get it let's find
out he bought a rock
it's like a gamble
it's like a mini game in a rpg now he's
sawing it open
what i can't believe this dude careful
[ __ ] oh
careful out there bro yeah oh no he's
gonna have jade in the middle
oh is that good or bad i can't tell oh
so like like how were people not dying
like look at this
yeah well unfortunately i think
people probably do yeah i mean this this
is super dangerous
yeah is there audio oh i pulled it down
because it was
music oh yeah you can pull that down
i'm captivated by this
let me hear if there's no music um
i saw someone mention the boys the show
yeah epic
what is this this guy nothing to do with
jade i get the
oh get off this hashtag look at this ela
wow i can't believe i just can't believe
what i'm seeing
i like it i mean it's like
the most interesting [ __ ] in some of
sheer tag on tick-tock
someone said world war z for sure
[Music]
i can't get i can't watch enough with it
i really can't
i don't know if you guys are bored but i
i love this [ __ ]
um
yeah okay i think we've seen it all
i'm over it okay just like at least just
i mean dude jadeite hashtag jadeite bro
all right so that's that yeah that's not
somebody saying there's something so
cool about
finding it you know what i mean like i
hope that it's
out there in the wild i hope that it's
more they're in it for the thrill and
not because they're desperate to like
buy
[ __ ] rice no i'm sure they're that
spread for their money but
it's so cool kind of
i think you're romanticizing yeah i
think it's cool for you
yeah i'll fly i'll buy you some jedi
i'll buy you a carriage
hide it in the house the same i don't
necessarily want like a necklace with
that one carat jedi thing i don't care
about that
you just want to find a stone yeah
all righty oh i wanted to start with
this so
i was i just mentioned the voice because
i'm like
maybe we should give a recommendation
bro i'm pissed about the boys they're
paying like
every influencer to promote them have
you noticed that
influence is getting paid and i'm out
here actually loving that [ __ ] show
and what i'm supposed to come here and
give them an endorsement for free now
you ain't guess yeah you're right
but have you noticed that it's like i
have not
it's very upsetting to me
i need better people yeah the boys rules
is the greatest show ever
on amazon unpaid
so you guys watched the finale yeah yeah
yeah
i guess we shouldn't really talk about
it now most people probably haven't seen
it yet but
no it's the best show ever though hey
this is me when i work out
you ever hear someone rip ass that fat
that's a good sound bite that oh my god
and then is that really him farting
yeah yeah he should explain right now oh
my god
i love how he's like
oh my god like everyone can hear that
are you father that's not added that is
so ridiculous no that's real
i have been isolated hit me with it
wow
[Laughter]
wait wait now play wendy williams oh my
god
now play that one
that's the best that is the best that's
the one huh
that's the best soundbite ever i think
he's [ __ ] his intestines he was saying
it's a meme sound effect dude
no they're lying not real they're lying
how do they know
oh it's added that's definitely not just
how do they know
because they're saying it's a tick tock
sound effect
sound bite i refuse to believe that
sorry
you find me the original clip and i
believe you wouldn't be able to hear it
that clearly
yeah no but he was under tremendous
strain
yeah i mean that's yeah um sounds like a
horse
baby fact check the chat are they right
all right give me one sec okay here now
speaking of tick tock because i'm i've
just i'm on tech talk all the time this
is my world now tick tock is my home
not enough by the way my sound bites oh
please
by the way um you notice how trump just
forgot about tick tock
it was like all this hub tick tock tick
tock and he's like oh
what is happening when they made a deal
no they didn't
what happened to the oracle uh he didn't
approve it
trump didn't approve it really who's
buying tick tock
no i don't know i thought it was the
oracle well they said last i heard was
that
you couldn't update or download the app
so i don't know can you download tech
talk is it is it there
i think it's still on the app store so
tick tock is not going anywhere
well have one of these guys look into it
trump agrees to tick-tock deal with
oracle and walmart yeah no i think i
think it it's all guilty
[Music]
last i heard it wasn't approved and it
was supposed to stop downloading
walmart is your home walmart right
finally anyway you're watching
walmart in the video this is so weird
now i'm watching a video in walmart
okay you know okay is this the best
prank ever
are you [ __ ] kidding me you thought
that right now what
six hours later pretending to sneeze on
people
during cover what's that bro did you
just sneeze on me
this guy's at least wearing a man
[Music]
and then it hits like a review process
and and the views stop coming or
whatever
these guys are getting approved these
are getting manually approved well if
you put this on youtube i'm pretty sure
you would get banned right but it's
owned by china and they
are trying to undermine our democracy in
the world order
like a cut gee i mean oh [ __ ]
it was at this moment that he knew he
[ __ ] up
all right yo it's not a prank you
slapped him in the head you dip [ __ ]
it's a prank bro how was that a prank
you [ __ ]
why why would you do that
well i do think it's fake because would
you really chase someone down a moment
yeah that's gotta be hey i'm gonna chase
you down punk and you know [ __ ]
walmart
i hate it you gonna let me [ __ ] [ __ ]
me a long time
huh took me a long
[ __ ] long time bro you really just
hang around walmart [ __ ] with people
bruh
damn you should go mine jadeite so
they're saying content chord
content card yeah not bad
the fart was the guy's original sound i
mean there are ways around it but
i couldn't find anywhere else that's his
original sound that's his original sound
thank you av are you gonna
you're gonna stand on that a b behind
that statement
zach do me a favor can you put reverb on
the fart and play it
reverb yes yeah one reverb
like i want like a big empty room av are
you going against the whole
chat they're wrong i'm saying there's
ways around it but
as as the way it shows right now that is
his original sound yo the chat
is [ __ ] with you is it a sound bite
and tick tock could you find it
no i cannot find it in tik tok
if someone has it send it to me
that's a real [ __ ] fart sound i think
the chat versus a b
need to show up in court okay wordy
there is a video from 2013 with it let's
see the video let's see it
oh there you say that there's proof
let's see the proof i'm calling you out
wordy in the chat you got a video once
again somebody's playing
a video in 2013 let's see the video well
how do i get it
i'm asking him to send the link send a
link on the discord let's see the link
send a link [ __ ] exactly working on
that reverb part
yeah i can't wait for this fan the link
so in the meantime this is a war the
people
against a b no i'm on a b's time i'm not
the people
he's got it's ethan in a b you're the
people
okay um i got the video but it looks
like it might be a little like split
should i watch it
yeah watch it by yourself and then pass
it to us if it's not crazy
i have deja vu from this didn't we have
another controversy about a fart just
like this
for a b and stepping up i don't believe
that was the wendy williams
wasn't here during the week yeah maybe
it wasn't in the wendy times do you want
to read off some donors
that's what he does first dan can we
check ian's shot because i didn't get
a good look at it before you read the
donors dan
oh okay let's see
i've got a good puke story with picture
you with pictures thank you for the
donation
thank you for always lifting my mood
love from denmark
oh thank you that now that's a great
comment yeah
thank you uh you see this pollen has
been around since 100k
subs
i really think another line interview
would be great he said
yeah i'll be into that that's so
interesting that
he watches since then i feel like i
don't even know myself so 100 around 100
000 subscribers we were
like doing our early early reaction
videos i think
in our in israel i think we just
passed a hundred thousand when we were
leaving israel
right oh no it's a fart fetish porn fart
no way i think it's a match guys
whoa but that one's good that one's
really good too wait so wait this this
one's from 2013.
so i think it's pretty incredible that
by the way
it's pretty incredible that he
referenced
this fart sound from this fart fetish
video back in 2013.
although it is a very popular one a
million views
but props to her i guess i probably
shouldn't show this
i think can you not show it
yeah it's still yeah it doesn't move
it's fine okay
not even their videos yeah
15-second mark the synagogue
so because you thought that was
cartoonish she's not even lifting
she's just laying there so wait if you
find his unbelievable you should find
hers really unbelievable
right dan uh
wait wait wait did she [ __ ] her pants
there's not much space
i mean the the clenching matches with
the uh
the pace of the fart pretty well so all
right zach hit me with that reverb
no not good enough i need echo like a
big
like and after or premiere they have
reverbs
presets the one i'm thinking looking for
is cathedral
huge empty room echoey put a i put a
i put a cathedral reverb you did didn't
sound like it
no maybe it's just too noisy you know
it's
so someone asked when will we be selling
the shirt that i wore on the tom and
christina podcast that's part of the
women's
uh drop and you know it's crazy that's
already next
week oh that's so exciting our first
female drop
we're releasing so much
let's [ __ ] go hater s [ __ ]
do you see this one from rory 100 just
donated 100 bucks and just said more
slamming
and you know what you ask
more shall receive more more more
ferrari more
more more thank you
uh you guys want to look at bad tattoos
we haven't looked at these in a while we
have some
really good contests um
do you want more chats sure
there was a dude that i saw donating a
bunch of money yeah i'm trying to go
back
hey abe can you figure out isn't that
what ian was talking about yeah i'm
trying to hear
victor whoa whoa did you read what ian
said where
what just read what ian said
why is it not um
i don't have it a b can you find out
what's the deal with tick tock because i
heard last time
yeah it's it's still in the app store
yeah but what was the latest update it's
just all good now
let me check okay you guys won't look at
bad tattoos i do
okay great
so this one's not that bad i mean i feel
like it's not
great but really i mean it's not great
but like i've seen so much worse
i mean there's definitely worse than
this album but i mean it's taking up a
lot of real estate
yeah cloud raining that's my
my one comment is like maybe not as big
it's tripping me out because it looks
like small holes
oh yeah you're figuring your uh what is
the phobia that you said that you had
the small hole phobia yeah really crypto
tryptotrope
tryptophobia anyway this one's not bad
though i'm not going to be too hard on
the kid
it looks like it's got fur
so this one is boy what is this
denny lane it's just a dog on a hand oh
the hand
yeah that's a rough spot but it's not
that bad either yeah he loves his dog i
mean how am i gonna hate on a guy for
loving his dog
you know
new aryan now this is bad new aryan
empire with trump as the fuhrer
finally somebody's saying everyone's
like trump's not a white supremacist
meanwhile
okay
okay i don't know if trump's a white
supremacist but
he'd have a hard time disavowing this
tattoo
listen there's a lot of good tattoos on
his body
i'm not gonna make distinctions it's his
preference
new aryan [ __ ] empire let's go
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
wow that's that is bad
[ __ ] police the okay obviously but [ __ ]
what happened what yeah is this an eye
the eye looks like a c
[ __ ] bulky
you know i feel like this guy was trying
to hide a previous tattoo or something
what could it possibly be hiding yeah
what was that
because the letters look so awful you
know i think it's just awful
i think it's just awful unfortunately
for him he's flexing by the way too look
at that
look at that ooh so jacked
this one was highly uploaded
shrek and batman had a bait or shrek is
pregnant oh my god and it was
honest i think it's funny actually i'm
not funny yeah
i'm not even horrible but kind of funny
let's do that again zach
it's funny because vin diesel sounds
interestingly similar to that
play the both of them one after the
other
zach buffering buffering buffering
what's
that what's happening i think he might
have been
and then where's our boy vin diesel
um no good no good huh
i'm confused i played both of them did
yeah yeah you must have lagged or
something
okay we didn't hear the first one
that's all right anyways moving i get
the idea i have a tick tock update
hold on okay go ahead so the deadline
was pushed to november 12th
um so walmart and oracle announced they
will buy a majority 20
stake in tick-tock and trump gave him
their blessing
um so yeah so oh so they're collabing on
it now
yeah right but it's not finalized yet
it's not finalized but trump is actually
pro for this deal he says it will lead
to five billion investments in education
in the u.s
um but it's cool like dance yeah
dude do we know how much they're paying
for the 20 percent
[Music]
um i'm not seeing it in this article a
lot of cash
yeah okay ready for this one you can
unfollow me on instagram
but you can't un talk untuck
unfuck my dick oh my god
okay cool sign me up daddy chill
something is wrong with this so do you
think he shows this to girls before
after he [ __ ] them
probably after anything he's like
caillou
okay let me read this again you can
unfollow me on instagram
but you can't unfuck my dick
that is brutal it's kind of deep it's
kind of like
some old ancient greek philosophy if you
just said this original
just i mean it really is a good pair i
mean be careful
you can't [ __ ] a dick son
daughter let me tell you something i
learned on a tattoo
you can't unfuck a dick my dick is
always dry
mine to we have a cat
peeing on the moon thoughts
garbage weird but not not the worst
thing ever
well i mean this one really struck me
they're not the worst we've seen
well certainly not but i mean if you had
a cat on the moon
why is it taking away the dick and the
pee it's like kind of an okay tattoo
right
but then just why what it's peeing in
its mouth too it's like pissing in the
moon's mouth i am with you that it's
weird dan
i fully admit to that it's just we're in
the business of like really horrible
tattoos you i mean dude
come on okay bro come on that guy is
definitely you can't unfuck my dick dude
this guy that's a tattoo that will put
you on the fbi list yeah
like we we were thinking in prayer it's
like prior when we did the
tier list it's like will you drop this
person from your life if you see that
right yes yes yes this no no
this is like wow strange but okay yeah
they probably have a story some kind of
story for it
oh dude this is the worst bro i saw this
and i was cracking up
so it's supposed to look like a tattoo
but or a butterfly i guess but it just
looks like she [ __ ] herself
[ __ ] man that's so crazy
that was good that was good so what you
need to do is pull out the
end and fade it out so it's not a hard
cut try it again
yeah so just fade it out at the end so
it does not a hard cut
yeah that was nice
[Laughter]
go ahead play it again while we're
looking at her ass
like that what happened
well don't go in the pool after diarrhea
they say
only only a king
can only attract a queen
a queen can keep king focused
isn't really crossed so it kind of just
like maybe locusts or uh
focused this strikes me as like you know
what cares what is this like i have a
theory
like you know how we get like uh chinese
or japanese symbols and don't know what
they are oh
they don't speak english i think it's a
non-english speaker
i feel like english is such a universal
language though that
not in like china you know
i feel like i mean there's a lot of
places where people don't universally
speak
english yeah but to come to the point of
making a tattoo on yourself
hey people do it all the time with it
with
only a king can only attract a queen
like how can it make so little sense
the queen can keep king focused
this is oh that's so [ __ ] foul this
is just unacceptable
what is that it's two in the pink one in
the stink
yeah yeah this is disgusting called the
shocker
it's so [ __ ] what wait what
it's called the shocker why is there a
name i didn't know that yeah i mean i
learned
so much from you it's just a joke no
yeah people have said that forever
i think that's why there's the lightning
bolt too it's the shocker
is that a guy thing like would any girl
know that
i mean i don't know why but i feel like
when i was in high school everybody knew
what the shocker was
just one of those yeah dirty jokes
everybody would always talk about
but dude this is i would disown you bro
for this one how wait so this is his
armpit
ew and then this is his gut oh it's on
his side
oh so everyone can see it good yeah
fantastic i'm sure he'll have many
interested females yeah
freaking weirdo i survived the global
pandemic and all i got was this stupid
tattoo
i agree it's very stupid um you haven't
survived yet
yeah yeah all right it's whatever
ew is this a female or a guy a guy it's
a guy
all right disgusting
what is wrong with you son
[Music]
boy you're [ __ ] in the head so what
happens
once you shave does the hair grow over
the tattoo or does it stop growing there
it grows over what do you mean you shave
cause i've
no but i've never seen i feel like you
never really see hair over
it yeah it'll grow over it just because
people shave it
it'll grow yeah my friend got a wolf
tattoo
and the hair keeps growing over it he
just ended up leaving it because he got
sick of cleaning it up he's like
whatever it's a wolf
it's the fur thoughts on this one
that looks like a photoshop that's real
dude what is wrong with you
bro
and of course yeah i always have to
include that just for comparison you
have to give him a pass
he dude i mean look we just went through
some of the most vile [ __ ] i've ever
seen
and you really gonna give you poor
benefit
[ __ ] no i i start to
this dude exists as time goes by this
dude
imagine you're dating a guy and then
like you know you're going a few dates
you guys are having fun
you're enjoying each other's company
take her back home and all of a sudden
talk to me baby do you leave
yeah yeah yeah would you
because like you this is someone you're
friendly with you guys are really
getting along
wouldn't you be too shy like yeah you
you but yeah yeah you couldn't put a
ring on that
no i mean something's gotta be kind of
cuckly there
right that's [ __ ] crazy that's the
worst that's
maybe that's the worst tattoo ever
i think it might be that was fun
that was hot why is my why am i
scrolling
infinitely to the bottom that's hot
what in god's name is going on let's see
okay the original fart source is from
big but
girl farts on youtube whoa there's like
dude this is like you know how have you
seen the movie um
unforgiven there's this guy who's trying
to do a document
a documentary on like the real cowboy
the real deadly shooter
and he thinks he's found it but he's
just a phony and then he finds the real
this is what's happening here he's
finding the real source
every time you saying that that one is a
ripoff
the one that we watched no no they said
the original fart source is from big
buck girl farts that was the name of the
video
no um bat tattoo tearless from the crew
i think only a b has tattoos oh yeah i
don't think anyone has tattoos
then i'm not gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] on i
don't think that's what they meant
of rating our tattoos i think it is what
they meant oh
i've decided i'm going to get a swastika
above my penis
um this couple this guy said my fiance
and i love you guys no joke my fiance
has a big
crush on you ethan oh a man crush
man crush wait whoa whoa whoa whoa hang
on hang on oh
yeah are they a gay couple or she like
literally
like i can't even joke about her liking
you it's a man crush
no it's uh kayla and josh so what does
it mean she has a man crusher no josh
has a man crush on you oh yes see that
i'm used to
it's always the boyfriends and then the
girlfriends just kind of get
come along right no they're both fans
but he has a crush on you
i'll suck his dick bring him over here
kayla
it's also the four year anniversary
today
and our anniversary is tomorrow eight
years marriage i'm gonna be
where are you congratulations oh my god
congratulations
you're coming to hug me
yeah that's what happens on the eighth
year anniversary you go to pee
nope you guys gonna light some of those
candles for anniversary yeah exactly
let's set the mood
uh let's see we got some more uh dr
shook 50
one last shout out to aaron goldberg on
twitch before my membership expires he's
the best around nothing's
gonna ever keep him down i don't know
who that is i
uh i can't um endorse him because uh
because i don't know who he is but dr
shug gives you a shout out aaron
um can you guys please consider using
transparent screws
on the after dark side it really pains
the ocd
folks no
i think they have a point then i covered
the wire because they were complaining
about the wire
oh you did that yeah when i was over the
other day
okay but you're in charge of the screws
oh [ __ ]
a rear screws you freaking they make
them
one last shout out to aaron goldberg
that was one i just read okay yeah
i love the show been around since the
just since the right height no bucket
required have a great one
yeah that was like the greatest meme
at that time jrh nbr well you know
when i posted a recent tick talk about
uh what the horse is [ __ ] in the
background
there was a lot of people who were who
were writing just the right height no
bucket required so that's great
there's a lot of that out there such an
epic
dude but like if we ever try to make a
video about it
come up with that oh it's a whole
community
it was a community no bucket required
yeah
just the right height and then
like they made a whole documentary about
these freaks and put it on tv
bro i watched that whole documentary it
was so disturbing i
just couldn't believe what i was
couldn't believe what i was seeing like
there was a couple
if you guys don't know what we're
talking about we're talking about like
an old old school reaction video
uh called anim what do we call it animal
love or something
it's about a bunch of people who are
into zoo zoology
zoo zoo zoo are you trying to say people
that are into having sex with animals
yeah yeah yeah but there's like
zoophilia zoophilia right yeah
someone said they have a story about
their dead
ex who tried to murder them three times
he was into diapers and humiliation and
everything crazy
sounds exciting she sounds like a good
light-hearted story let's get it right
yeah let's get this [ __ ] crazy
you on that zach yeah have them dm me
whoever the person is who is that
talk about your music oh um
dude that's crazy i can play my music
and not get claimed it's my [ __ ]
music
i mean there's not much to say about it
you know
it is what it is right
what you have a specific question for me
there was no question
it just says talk about your music
since i met him he was kind of just
always uh
playing the guitar randomly hey
here we just put out this new song
we i just put out this song this is my
my buddy from college we've
always played music together why'd you
mute it it's my song
oh i paused it
this is my body we always play music
together and he's like a genius he's a
music genius
baby i don't know how you're good all
the time
yeah i just posted on youtube
it's just a fun thing we do together i'm
really serious baby she's an angel on
this earth i really like this one
thank you so much i did too it's really
good dude
i mean i like them all oh thank you
thank you thank you
anything else you want to add i like all
your songs thank you
and the ones that you're you started but
haven't finished
thank you
so you uh so um i will meanwhile wait
for the girl who
uh with the crazy the crazy dead
boyfriend my crazy dead boyfriend
i feel like that's a show i haven't
heard anything
in the meantime oh make ethan laugh
i could go for this right now if you
guys don't remember we have a segment on
the show
make ethan laugh you have one minute to
make me laugh and if you succeed
i give you 100 bucks boom
100 bucks uh
michelle do we have her available um
so i can set it up right now yeah set
that up it's exciting
in the meantime
dude i gotta tell you i i have a hatred
for chiropractors
chiropracty chiropractors is that right
yeah they're such [ __ ] quacks bro
they walk around acting like they're
doctors
so many arguments with friends such a
pseudoscience
oh my god it's such a pseudoscience
like just use your head dude how is
cracking your bones gonna [ __ ]
fix your [ __ ] up back you know what i
mean
chiropractor yeah yeah i have a michelle
ready bring her in
we're going to i have a whole thing
about chiropractors set up in our and
this week and we meet again uh men of
culture
she's on the call right now okay
michelle hello
all right one second oh
how are you doing today i'm doing good
how are you
you feeling confident um yeah
i think so i think i got a pretty good
start okay
can you do it in one minute
dan did we lose her i still see her in
the
channel michelle michelle i think that
means you failed
it's gonna be difficult if we can't hear
you
okay i'll try again later
so i find that all chiropractors are
creepy dudes too
who just wanna would you just wanna like
feel up women
you went to the chiropractor once did he
ever touch you inappropriately
no no okay just wondering
i had to ask well this guy does for sure
this
this guy he's pretty popular on youtube
but i think he just makes porn
and he thinks he's like the dalai lama
or some [ __ ]
hot latino getting adjusted by dr jason
that's what he titles it no it looks
like someone ripped it
that's part of the show here we go
but let's look up dr jason on youtube
by the way bro are you really a [ __ ]
doctor dr jason doesn't sound like a
real doctor name
what you who says doctor in their first
name
it's like dr phil he's not a doctor
active let's see if he's a doctor yeah i
don't think he is
he's a liar i mean
i am a ship for dr phil what didn't he
put his credentials
in the description
it well his name was dr jason something
dr jason rox
here
so anyway he does really creepy
adjustments like this one here
this is his relax
there we go a little bit of motion right
like who first of all who the [ __ ] goes
to a chiropractor in a short dress
that's literally would never happen ever
ever ever ever ever yeah hey let me see
what dr phil simp
oh sam all right we're here today with
miss maria how are you young lady
jason nice to see you and uh we first
met over at uh wells fargo right
this is the cast oh what bro this is
straight up casting call
i think it's been a little overwhelming
why is this room coming for your
alignment yeah like a year and a half
yeah maybe even two years right it's
been a minute but we've been touched
loosely
also like it matters about this
backstory too oh
dude i always knew backstory my porn
makes it way better
but just imagine this like okay i'm
gonna do some adjustments but i'd like
to
film it i'd like to film talking to you
yeah i gotta get in and right um how's
the body doing
my back is killing me okay snap where
where should i
snap did you say snap oh snap whole
upper back and then my tailbone
okay so let me ask you this so let me
ask you this what is the appropriate
occasion to wear high heels
and a short dress i feel like um
she's a paid actress right is that that
way for sure for sure yeah because it
has to be
yeah so we wanted we met at wells fargo
we were both
standing in line to make a deposit
and one thing led to another and here we
are
[Music]
sacrum is right here and the tailbone is
like a little lower than where i am now
so it's really down there
okay so what happened and up here what
happened
this one i'm going to start with that
what happened down there i have an idea
did you fall down or give a [ __ ] just
fix her back
no do you think maybe from does it hurt
when you sit
when i sit or when i stand no no when i
stand when you stand no
how about getting up if you're getting
up to just getting up and standing yeah
got it and you ever wear heels i haven't
even looked yeah
look at the heels all the time all the
time
okay all right i haven't even the
chiropractor yeah yeah you know
you asked her to wear those freaks so
the lower back sacral area uh coccyxial
area is hurting and then the mid-back
what's going on here
it feels tense it feels really tense all
right let's go look at this
uh brook raver after i suffered a severe
spinal injury the chiropractor actually
caused temporary paralysis and i had to
learn to walk again
holy [ __ ] i would like to talk to that
person
yeah dude they're not qualified this
guy's not a doctor at least as far as i
can tell they don't
they're not actually md's you know what
i mean they're just
[ __ ] around and he's like oh you got
heels let me see them shoes
you know
by the way and you know that
chiropractor that made this poor person
paralyzed was probably like okay that's
supposed to happen yeah don't worry
so you're temporarily going to be not
able to walk but your body
is really it's going to be rewiring and
you're going to come back
stronger how convenient to say like it's
going to feel
bad at first it's going to it's going to
feel horrible it's going to feel hot
you're going to be very painful
another person i just bought this uh
donated twenty dollars to say
uh they joining in on your frustration
of hidden chiropractors the other
day i saw youtube video of a newborn
baby getting an adjustment and i think
it should be illegal
why would a baby need no adjustment they
can't even communicate
your bones aren't even fully formed oh
that is so upsetting exactly if you were
a real doctor you wouldn't do that
i mean you would like obviously they're
in the discord
um zach the face
all right dr jason let's see what you
got
shoulders relax breathe in
like do you really think she has chronic
back pain do you
understand what what what she's saying
chronic back pain and this dude's like
all right i got you
yeah i think that's def
definitely like just porn this yeah for
sure
this for sure a lot of tension dr jason
i can't thank you oh he's a popular
youtube channel he has a lot of
content so are the
he has even had some like influences
there and stuff
here before we finish watching this i
want to show you
no this guy was like a social phenomenon
for a while and i was like i hate him i
hate him he has a million subs
uh dr jason warhol dc
yeah d.c exactly
look up what is dc doctor of
chiropractic yeah how many how much year
how much years of education to get a dc
oh holy [ __ ] so exactly all of his top
videos are porn
yeah dude [ __ ] you you creepy
[ __ ]
because he had like influencers trying
to act all legit and then he has 100
million 100 million views
of dr jason
i guess people like the sound apparently
but it's it's four years of school four
years
yeah yeah and you're not you don't have
an md degree
you're you're not so you're not a
medical doctor but you're a doctor of
chiropractic
so four years is
very low is this a post-graduate four
years or is it like
four years of college because i went to
college for five years i'm not a [ __ ]
doctor i don't know anything
that's after undergrad this is an
undergrad
no after underground okay
how do you go to post grad for
pseudoscience
i really don't know you're going deep
either
that's looking on dr jason
so anyway let's watch hot latina gets
adjusted
you do this all day for many years you
can feel it
all right so we're going to the appeal
to authority when you do this for as
many years
then you can see that it's not actually
[ __ ] like what you probably are
afraid of it is
i have the person with the story bring
it in and talk to them bring them in
who are they there it's uh
young
yeah can you turn it up hi can you hear
me touchdown yes we can hear you brooke
hi okay how are you guys so um
what brought you into the uh doctor
jason
has an only fence no don't
don't you dare tell me that you're
kidding me
that sounds about right dude what the
[ __ ] i guess he wasn't making enough
money with chiropractor
honestly it's a really like oddly erotic
thing
and i was only like 17 and i came in
after
getting hit by a car holy [ __ ] um
so i was already um
i had lost um movement in both both my
hands because of the way the car hit me
so i i severed or i bruised my spinal
cord
and it was a whole deal but i went to
the chiropractor
because my mom broke her back
like years and years ago and she's like
oh it's great it's a great experience
you're gonna totally feel fine
and as soon as he went down to crack my
back
my legs just went numb oh my god jesus
oh my god
and i i was i started freaking out
obviously because i was like
um i can't feel my legs
and he's like okay try to get up for me
and i couldn't
because i was literally laying face down
on this like chiropractic
like thing i so i started freaking out i
already suffered like
major anxiety and so after this whole
traumatic event
whole like healing process got movement
back in my hands i'm like hell yeah
i just have back pain i get
wheeled to the hospital and the guy like
the emt who picked me up was like
what happened i'm just like
i asked the chiropractor and it turns
out the guy who um
owned the practice was giving pills out
to people
so he breaks you back and he gives you
the medicine oh my god oh
yeah so he was like popping pills and
stuff and acting up like
it was weird but then like going to the
hospital
and like literally having all of the
nurses
after probably two weeks in the icu from
a car accident
saying oh what happened to your legs
that was horrific you're breaking out a
little bit yeah
can you hear me
they dropped out is it us we keep having
issues with callers i don't
think so well we're streaming fine so
it's probably not yeah i mean
they like actually left the channel i
think their discord like disconnected
back i'd love to talk more with her she
comes back if she comes back
um i want to know i mean i have so many
questions i see some people in the chat
saying
uh no that's not true chiropractors are
it's not suicides um
yes it is do some research it absolutely
100
is a pseudoscience well does someone
want to come defend chiropractory
because i'll talk about it let's have a
dialogue
i've personally tried it and it didn't
do anything for me
um uh we're signing up for dr jason's
only fans by the way
zac you're on that right
yeah he's on it he's working on it okay
guys i dropped some pictures in the
discord oh you did [ __ ] yeah yeah
oh dude what the [ __ ] it's just him
oh it's literally shorter let me show
you how much did we just spend on this
seven dollars here this is what you got
for seven dollars from dr jason
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's like thanks for the seven dollars
here's to you idiot
we don't even get to see dick why the
[ __ ] does this guy have an online fan oh
there's no dick well
it says in the description he has
exclusive pics adjust
adjustment videos and workout videos
where are those we just dropped buying i
don't
maybe it's some more exclusive tier yeah
so wait what is this photo zack of him
adjusting a girl and with some cleavage
out
like it's literally just posted why is
this on his only fans
that's just his youtube wait no it says
onlyfans.com
that's what i'm on right now dude and
that's literally it there's no
explanation
well if anyone knows their way around
only fans it's definitely you so
i'm not gonna question you here you hold
yourself together
literally just him running and hold
yourself together
dr jason's on it you want to get
adjusted by this superstar he's got a
star on his
bicep weirdo so this
just kind of proves that for him it's
like a sexual
it's like a weird sexual thing right
i mean that definitely adds to our
the creepiness anyway here's dr jason
i wonder if he pitches his only fans to
his patients like jimmy lee
and uh if you are interested to learn
more you can hit me up on onlyfans.com
dr jason exclusive workout videos
and adjustments just remember it's not
the bones rubbing together right
it's nitrogen gas releasing from your
joint so we're going to breathe in nice
and deep miss maria
all the way out i'm going to breathe in
again
hold your breath and lift your head up a
little bit
how do we do okay good there we go we
got some movement right
okay we're gonna breathe in again you
guys literally all he's doing is
cracking her bones
yeah what is that supposed to do long
term nothing
like he's right that there's there's gas
in your joints and that's what makes the
cracking sound
there we go a little bit of motion right
and it make
it gives you this this uh placebo that
he's doing something because it makes
the sound
hips relaxed i'm gonna check and it's
like super intense because
it is very painful on the right side and
intense your sacrum is that bone
right before the cost and by the way
look what's going on here i mean let's
be honest
right down here what's he's [ __ ]
crying around
so this is that hurts right there that's
the right sacral custodial junction
he's fingering your bottle a little bit
i'm sorry if it hurts
he's just straight giving her the
shocker
is it more over there big time right
dude that's right
that's like right on a [ __ ]
and i'm gonna just go up your skirt here
real fast so what we're going to do
is we're going to start out with you
just bring that there
bring that down a little bit there on
your right side facing me this way
come on over this way yeah on your side
so bring your arm all the way over with
your
[Music]
right here so first we're going to do
the lumbar spine and we're going to go
just like that but this room is so
freakily small i'm going to contact here
and then i'm going to lean over you
because the force comes between the hips
or the pockets
i'm just waiting for the crack so breath
in all the way up
okay get ready to be cured shoulders
relaxed
just like that you're ready all the way
about yeah just cured your ass
it was a big motion that was a big
motion do you really think that the
human body
doesn't go back to its or where it was
yeah
it's not what is he changing
anyway [ __ ] doctor jason no dick pics
aren't uh zach
unfortunately no no dick pics damn seven
bucks all right let's see what 100
million views of this [ __ ] gets you
well please note the thumbnail because
it is just a woman's ass
so he knows what he's doing dirty
[Music]
sounds kind of like a fart
i mean i wouldn't really put it past
them to edit the sound oh my gosh
oh you think they're adding i don't
think so because the video with the girl
like it's all in question for me
i mean she seems like right right
because they're actually once you pay
once you have an actor yeah
well was there there was big cracks when
your chiropractor was
tinkering with you
why would you film your client who would
be okay with that
yeah and it's handheld too so there's
somebody in there with a camera handheld
it's not like on a tripod
wow all the way out
head drop relax got angry uh
chiropractic bring them in
messaging me bring them on i'm ignorant
to say that's a suit bring them on let's
talk to them let's get to the bottom of
this you tell me how
cracking a [ __ ] bone will help cure
chronic back pain
bringing i don't know how to get them in
here someone dm me that wants to dm jack
if you want to bring this to the
gauntlet
someone chiropractic
on wikipedia the first line chiropractic
is a pseudoscientific
complementary and alternative medicine
it's considered
concerned with the diagnosis and
treatment of medical disorders based on
your
skeletal system well you know people
swear by um
people swear by uh that's the one where
they put the needles in you
there you go acupuncture acupuncture is
like
bro they invented that [ __ ] like 2000
years ago you really think
putting little needles in you know
there's no science behind it that's what
makes it pseudoscience
it's it's not
real medicine dr
jason years of back pain
helped look at this one
she's got a see through spandex 70
million views you sing this [ __ ]
what we're going to do is we're going to
find an area of your spine
dislikes disabled arms drop down this
way actually
and then we're going to put the head up
here yeah like that so we want the
chest to rest there and then it's not
sure okay or do you want a pillow we
have a pillow
that's okay okay cool um now what we're
going to do is start here in the mid
back
and just to show you again dr jason's
the type of dude to wear like a magnetic
bracelet
when the fart i love that reverb
definitely put it over the top so you're
going to feel the movement and hearing
noise and the noise
oh she's about to feel movement zach
that sort of movement would be a balance
your bones rubbing together is nitrogen
gas releasing from the joint does that
make sense yeah yeah yeah we know
nitrogen gas stand out chest relaxed
this is funny there's a reason
chiropractors work
next to panda express and not in the
hospital
[ __ ] true because dan is first and
foremost a scientist roll eye emoji okay
alexandra
you don't have to be a scientist i mean
[ __ ] use your brain unbelievable
exactly i found someone that wants a
debate let's bring him on
let's go it's the poop lasagna person
wait what we have us huh wait from last
week
oh wow okay interesting we have our
first regular caller
what was her name again uh
rose rose rose rose rose are you there
she's enough rose
rose hello okay rose welcome back
now first of all if you've been helped
by chiropracty
i think that that's great and i'm not
saying that it's not possible they can
help you because a lot of people say
that placebos can have just a strong
effect
as real medicine so with that being said
tell me about your experience getting
your back cracked and why do you think
dan is wrong
i mean i'm not here to attack dan but um
my chiropractor they first of all
your your general practitioner has to
like sign off a thingy that yes this
person needs a chiropractor
and that way the insurance you know pays
for the treatments
and then the chiropractor i went to she
went to a school specifically for
chiropracti for five years
yeah but you know they have schools for
like holistic medicine too
yeah probably they do you can get a
degree in distilling lavender into an
essential oil
that apparently cures cancer i swear to
god
um but maybe this is my ignorance that i
am the fact that she went to a school
and got in
any education makes me believe that okay
she's somewhat trustworthy
well i think my chiropractor was yeah
she was also anti-vaxxed
so maybe dude come on what are we doing
here you're not gonna open the cause
you can't you're not she did change my
life and i did start crying after the
procedure
procedures um
if you'd like i can disprove dr jason
first of all the woman is in high heels
the first thing they tell you is take
your shoes off so you're like flat on
the ground
and then they did a bunch of tests to
see your balance
um your eye coordination yeah your eye
movement to your
body coordination to see how your brain
was connected to the rest of your body
and
um sorry can i get can i get a
commitment from you to buy
a smells like my butthole candle right
now on the phone
um it's all it's in my checkout no joke
75 can i count on you we need to sell
250 of these things
thank you am i paying euros sure of
course we can convert those
right absolutely we can ship anywhere we
gotta we got to unload these
so in short you're saying that dr jason
is a quack
but doctor is not real whoever and your
doctor was
was it definitely chiropractor and not
physical therapy
some people are no like she even asked
me why are you not at the
theme above why are you not the the
physio
and why are you a chiropractor and i
told her like you know my bones are
really i already
always have a pain in one side i also
have ocd and she said okay cool because
your spine
is connected to your um brain so along
with the adjustment you give me
exercises yeah she didn't exercise like
you have to do this and like you know so
do you think
do you think the treatment helps it
changed my life
really oh it actually changed my life i
started crying after like the fourth
session
who am i who am i to question
and are you healed of that the pain that
you had before
indeed indeed very much you still do you
still go
um every four weeks like a lot shorter
in distance of time
less frequency and um
can you do me a favor and smell your
left hand for me
yes how's this fine
um a little no it's fresh or mustard i'd
wash it after i pooped i washed after i
pooped it smelled fresh that's
good all right thank you rose for the
anecdote nice to hear from you again
take care all right thanks for calling
well who am i to you know say hey yeah
if it helped her
she says it changed her life she cried
who am i
right that's right
you know that's hot dan thoughts
it's [ __ ] but it changed your life
how can you she's still going to a
chiropractor didn't cure anything
well she doesn't have pain anymore if
you just pay like 200
every four weeks and then if it works it
works i guess
it's a placebo though one hundred
percent
what then could i send dan to a
chiropractor and film it these people
are so
mad at me too for saying that it's
[ __ ] i'm sorry for the reality check
well the truth is if it does help but
yeah i mean it can be both a
pseudoscience and and and it can help
them yeah placebo
should be very effective it's true yeah
pseudoscience doesn't mean that it's not
effective altogether it means that
there's no
scientific basis for it hey do you think
dr jason gives happy endings
if i pay him a little extra will he
finish me off i think he does now
let's take a call in we've got collins
from
let me have someone that said the
chiropractor paralyzed their mom for
three hours
i wanted there's so many horses yeah no
i want to hear i want to hear that i
want to hear
about that yeah okay yeah setting it up
because i'm very curious about like what
happens
after they're paralyzed do you pursue
legal
action what do they say how did they
justify it
because like that shouldn't really be a
risk
where you walk out of a treatment
paralyzed
because some quack is doing [ __ ] wwf
body slams on your back
[Music]
here you want another compilation while
we wait what else we got
oh yeah you you've heard of dr jason
but have you heard of dr gabriel benelli
that's appropriate attire bro this guy
doesn't this guy's not this guy's not
even a chiropractor
he's just like tough
yeah you really want to trust someone to
do that these basic
that's how people die in action movies
dude
you know what i mean same exact movement
i don't like it you don't like it i do
not like it you don't like dr gabriel
beneditti
he's got a stethoscope on his that's why
listen to the pulse in someone's foot
just because it snaps doesn't mean it's
good
oh got him whoa why is he wearing a
speedo dude
dude do you require them getting it
looks like it but why you freaking
[Laughter]
weirdo
by the way this guy looks like he's like
23.
okay okay can you walk can you still
walk
why are all the patients like attractive
you know what i mean
right i agree oh
let's see some some fat people
this is so weird
okay well men of culture i don't know if
we meet again here today or what's going
on
hot cheerleader model chiropractic
adjustment dicks out zach
that's there and then oh we've seen this
jason's dr jason bro
whoa he's giving her a damn he's trying
to bring her back online
oh that's what i'm saying look it's
amanda kearney like they're doing
dr jason did amanda kearney amazing
cerny whatever she's dead she never
walked the gun
big smile hey follow me on fans
so do you think she would have still
done this if she knew he had only fans
um like bro you really out there
touching all these people and
making the only fans are you done for
today
you know next my package
let's bring her back alive okay her
pulse is stopped let's bring her back
that looks really healthy that's great
hands on you tell me let me have your
legs
whoa look at this she's got a towel
around her neck
oh look at her she's in pain
keep breathing okay keep breathing
there you go i still got one here i want
you to tell yourself it says dr jason
has a video of him adjusting a newborn
no i can't watch that yeah he should be
dude
dude what the hell was that wait that
was [ __ ] ridiculous
that guy doesn't know what he's doing
this people should not he just slammed
her head like unexpectedly
and by the way didn't snap
that's like why is he grabbing her right
dude this ain't right
that's like what happens if you fall out
of a tree
[Music]
here comes when you least expect it can
you walk can you feel your legs
can you feel your legs okay stop trying
to kill her like [ __ ] steven seagal
all right do you have anything else yeah
no more characters
i think we've come to consi let's do a
straw poll can we do a straw poll
people who think it's fake and people
think it's real
sure i'm curious on the consensus
after all we've been through after all
we've talked about we need a conclusion
okay one second i'm setting it up
in the meanwhile i have something really
disgusting we can watch
you know i have that caller set up if
you still want to talk to her what is it
regarding she her mom was paralyzed okay
bringing her in now
her name is heather hello heather hi
hi so what why did your mom go to the
chiropractor
so my mom has severe scoliosis she had a
lot of birth defects as a kid
and she has two metal rods in her back
and so this was when i was about five so
this was back in like 2004
and she took me with her to an
appointment
and she went to this really creepy old
dude i'm from like west like
if you know where that is in l.a and
county yeah
let um put in headphones that'll fix it
that'll fix it that'll fix it that'll
fix it
[ __ ] hold on let me grab that car
i'm so sorry hey zach no it's okay zach
when you pre-call with people
make sure that they have headphones in
so that we don't have to explain it
no it was totally it was totally my bad
because i
wasn't able to talk for like two million
years
so what does that mean
oh i had a hard time connecting my mic
hello is that better yeah yeah yeah
there you go so you were in the room
with your mom she's getting the
the chiropractors doing his thing
yeah and he's no longer in fact all
chiropractors are dudes
yeah he's he's no longer in practice and
he had
he sold his practice to someone else
that's um
anyways dr jason yeah so
no he was like a really old like white
guy with a beard he looked like weird
santa anyways and he did some maneuver
on my mom
and all of a sudden my mom was like
she started freaking out and the doctor
was like are you okay my mom's like i'm
trying to move but i can't move
and i just remember my mom like really
freaking out and i don't really remember
a lot but i just remember my mom like
yelling like she was so
[ __ ] mad because she lost like full
control of her body from like the neck
down
for three hours scary for three hours
and my mom had to go to the hospital
and i don't remember what they did
but or how they reversed this maneuver
but it i mean eventually it wore off
that's [ __ ] thank god for that yeah
so what what did the doctor say did your
mom sue
him what was the fallout from this
my mom didn't sue him and she stopped
going to a chiropractor
and about a year later is when he sold
his practice i remember what my mom said
was correct
what did he say did she confront him did
she try to get any explanation from him
did she get a refund for the visit
i oh she definitely got her money back i
know that for sure
but i mean i i don't think that i mean
she didn't even want to take it to small
claims because it's like
i feel like the whole thing in court is
also like you're a great
you're agreeing to having yourself
maneuvered that way
so it's like oh well you're kind of like
the idiot
in that situation that's not necessary
if you go to a doctor you don't expect
them
to like operate on the wrong leg or some
[ __ ] you go into a surgery and come out
crippled i mean
there's such thing as malpractice
that's true well it's ancient history
i'm glad your mom's okay though
so yeah me too so you you guys no longer
believe in chiropractic
oh no and i i mean i've never gone it
really freaks me out
i really also if it's just releasing gas
from a pocket
wouldn't that bath like exactly
let's get the gas it doesn't it doesn't
really make any sense i got plenty of
ways to get going
my mom went for her scoliosis and
i can tell you that she still definitely
has really horrible scoliosis
me too i mean i don't know if it's
horrible but i have it too
that's yeah well i wish you and your
mother lots of uh
lots of uh unparalyzed days
thank you thank you thank you much
appreciate you sharing your story god
bless you thank you
holy [ __ ] i can't believe what i'm
seeing
oh okay i had it backwards i was like
people after all that still
you know what 23 disagree with us
and that's okay you know
that's just fine it's okay
those are people that probably had
positive experiences from chiropractic
right and who am i to argue with
empirical you know
if it works for you god bless but just
know
you may [ __ ] walk in
and be could then be paralyzed and be
carried out yeah
yeah be carried out dude you might be
getting defibrillated
straight up well okay
ate up my ass eat out my ass
straight up oh we didn't do make ethan
laugh whatever happened with that
so our caller uh let's do it we'll get
someone in here quick
okay quick all right let me show you
some funny [ __ ] first of all
do you guys see this celebs getting
naked to encourage voting i don't know
why celebrities have to always do this
[ __ ]
it's like every time there's a mega
compilation of celebrities
it's always awful just stop
participating
stop it i'm naked
i'm completely butt ass naked i'm naked
i'm like naked there isn't a man behind
me these are
my hands why you want me to be naked
i know what you're thinking you're
thinking ruffalo um put your clothes on
to be honest i wish i could
cover my hands with my boobs but here we
are i'm here to talk to you about
voting did you know that cover hands
with their boobs
she said to be honest i wish i could
cover my hands with my boobs isn't that
what she's doing
no she wants to put her boobs over her
hands
but however that's possible ballads
could be naked and if you don't do
exactly
she got a lot of boob masks yeah yeah
are those natural swingers or i think so
because swingers well in this case
because they're pretty
[ __ ] just struck by the size of them
first of all when your ballot comes
you're supposed to read the instructions
read and follow the instructions that
come
with your ballot if they say to use the
black pen use a black pen
i know that's like literally the least
sexy thing a completely naked person
could say
but but i have cram like
can of pepsi this problem
number two in some states like
pennsylvania
pennsylvania pennsylvania there are two
envelopes
this doesn't help i always like to say
when i see a video like this like i'm
gonna vote twice now thank you have to
stuff
your ballot in otherwise it's called a
naked ballot
naked ballots and you don't want to have
one of those
number three mail your ballot in
as soon as you can don't sit on them
get those things out asap like
now do it it's not helping right no get
it in
as soon as you can i gotta get my ballot
did everyone vote though
okay yeah yeah we voted
oh no i i haven't i haven't you haven't
voted yet i haven't got my mailing
oh you mean the actual vote yeah yeah we
voted already i
haven't gotten my ballot in the mail
yeah
i haven't gotten my ballot yet no yeah
mine has also not come yet
i'm hoping it might be there today does
ai ian get to vote
no he's not i don't think they're
covered i don't think robots are covered
in uh they don't have a voice yeah they
don't have suffrage
hey i am um
i don't want to vote in this clown show
anyway
i'm just gonna sit back and watch it all
burn you know
hey check this out we're as we wait for
make ethan laugh
yeah this is just i love people who get
into the
i haven't set up if you want to okay let
me watch this okay
i love this dude
what what what
i'm trying to see i'm trying to see
who's driving because
come on what i i mean i feel like
who's who's in the car who's driving it
literally
could be anyone um
okay i accept that promise yeah i accept
that premise
i accept that premise you're right for
someone who just
ranted about pseudoscience no you're
right it could be anybody
let's see if it's a woman i didn't say
that hey i didn't say that how dare you
i did not say that
bruh i just love the there's such a
colossal impact
it's literally just a car garage you
just drive in a circle and this guy
managed to get into like
the most intense accident ever
you could just see their body being
racked up oh god
that's good there's a bunch of other
ones it's kind of like when i try to
play
racing video games right
it's that hard bouncing back and yeah i
don't know why this made me crack up
like
this dude is welding straight in his
[ __ ] face without a mask
and then the homie behind him has a mask
[Music]
i don't know why this dude's looking
through a man what the [ __ ]
dude what are you doing
why are you doing that yeah apparently
that's like super super super yeah
it's not not something i've done welding
you have i have welded yeah that's
pretty badass
why in my sculpture class
yo this woman comes over to help and she
crashes his [ __ ] car
watch this he stops the car
great we're good woman hops in the car
i'm gonna [ __ ] put it in park
he saved it it was all good
[Laughter]
he was all good he was safe
don't worry i got you
[Laughter]
oh so good so i've
i mean i've experienced what it's like
when you kind of look at it
because like in the workshop sometimes
people will be welding and you're like
accidentally look at it yeah but it
feels bad when you do it it's really bad
it feels like it's piercing your eyes
yeah i love it all right make me laugh
real quick real quick rory donated 50
said he's gonna keep
donating until he gets a slamming for
his sister she's going through a rough
patch
and could really use it and who who are
we
to deny
it's for you come on well that's for
your sister keep it going keep it going
come on that's it hit me with this
chase
all right who we got on the phone
michelle again all right michelle
this is it michelle michelle we don't
get three chances hi michelle
hi michelle can you hear me i can hear
you i can hear you
okay good okay so tell me so first of
all michelle
how are you feeling are you feeling
confident you said yes last time
a little less so now right
no i'm good i'm good and i'm ready okay
all right well i'm
getting the stopwatch ready we're gonna
put one minute on the clock
okay so everybody good to go okay so
everyone watch closely in the chat
everybody we're going to make a
distinction as a group if if michelle
succeeded or failed last time it was
uh half we get yeah we gave 50. yeah
right but i'm not [ __ ] around and let
me tell you michelle
i am not [ __ ] around you gotta commit
it's either like nothing
or if you exhale or something then you
lose well like a smile
i mean well let's let me do it and then
you guys just did the laugh you lose
thing on the show
we said any sound that you make like
okay
i'll i'll be right up to the mic so you
guys can tell so it's all right michelle
you have one minute are you ready dan
yeah i'm ready okay here we go in three
two one go all right so when i was a
little kid we were at the mall
and my grandfather had had a stroke
before
like a few years ago and he
had this issue where he would just poop
everywhere he walked
and wouldn't refuse to wear
boxer briefs or like tidy whities or
anything so he would wear these loose
boxers and the logs would just come
flying out of the bottom of his pants
and
uh so we were in the mall and he pooped
his pants and it was all over the floor
and then he started yelling at my
dad for pooping on the floor even though
it was him
and they were screaming at each other in
the middle of the mall about who pooped
on the floor
we went into the into sears to get him a
new pair of pants and underwear and when
we came back out
somebody had stepped in it slid across
the floor and threw up all over it
and then my mom made him sit in a
on a trash bag on the way home okay
your grandpa sounds like what and it's
it and it's time
i'm getting better at it i'm getting
better i laughed michelle i gotta say
that
i love too i'm protecting my hundred
dollars
to close his eyes why i'm listening it's
i'm ch i'm
i'm focusing he's trying to be in the
moment yeah i'm not sure i'm listening
to everything you're saying you want me
to keep my eyes open
[Laughter]
well michelle michelle i'm sorry you did
not make it any other great
it was absolutely that was a great story
is there any other uh good grandpa
pooping stories you'd like to share with
us yeah
uh my mom had to pick up his logs
literally everywhere and they were like
on the floor for the kitchen and like
on the toilet seat and he just wouldn't
clean them up
it bothers me i keep calling
[Laughter]
we were talking about this the other day
how you could tell which direction he
was going
based on
is he like senile or what why is he
[ __ ] his pants
yeah well he had a stroke and so he like
he's not alive anymore but he had a
stroke so he was just kind of like
a mess anyways and then he like had
diabetes and like would just
eat whatever he wanted all the time so i
think
um and i agree with the chat i think we
are all thinking
that she should get a 50 because we all
made a
really big laugh here when she said dude
i didn't last
directions stop we gotta observe the
rules of the game i can't just be giving
up
willy-nilly if you gave it to me it
would just go right back to teddy fresh
anyways
there you go it's the circle of life i
vote for a friend but wait
wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa i
mean i i i found it
after it was over but that's pretty hard
to
to achieve i wouldn't win dude what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ]
i'm with you i'm actually with you ethan
she had 60 seconds she didn't do it
no no no i don't deserve it i didn't do
it i didn't do it there you go
we have to it wasn't admirable guys we
have to keep the integrity of the game i
can't be giving out pity money every
time somebody calls
but it was funny and i thank you very
much for sharing
yeah thank you for having me thank you
so much
spanish it's just nothing but guys
we have to keep the integrity of the
game thank you michelle thank you
i feel like you guys aren't appreciating
my success
and not laughing oh yeah no i'm just
appreciating her success and getting a
loud laugh from you because it's very
hard yeah it was great we all enjoyed it
you know you that's too cool
[Music]
you guys really know how to get me the
first one was about his brother pooping
on a slide and like
cleaning out the pool of disney right
yeah
the second one about grandpa taking a
dump on them off on the floor should we
do one more
before we just one more let's do one
more thank you for people backing me up
i can't this is we're not just handing
out money
no you're right you're right you there
were parameters
and she did not meet them so what can
you do
okay well zach sets up one more
you want another make ethan laugh or yes
yes
okay if you can come up with somebody
okay
you want to watch a woman get beat up by
kangaroo
yup you know i do
remove the fridge
video should still work though what it
[ __ ] dumps her ass in the trash can
dude oh my god
like a bully in high school
dude kangaroos are so jacked they're
like little
men disturbing and then he starts
choking her out i don't like it how did
she even end up in the ring with that
thing man
well i think this is some terrible event
what is this terrible
event they're like hey back it up to the
kangaroo like he knows i'm assuming in
australia that kangaroo looks so scary
like that
we have a lot of australian fans is this
like a thing yeah what is this
it's not a thing how do they get shorts
on the kangaroo
bro have you seen like super muscular
kangaroos they're crazy
kangaroos uh they're kind of scary with
like especially like that with those
with the outfit like yeah that was a
small one what did you see like these
huge jacked ones
okay look at this [ __ ] bro swole as [ __ ]
like
looking like dr jason right this guy
this kangaroo got only fans or what
dude they're such a cool creators they
literally bounce on their tails and drop
kick each other
i don't understand how it's real
sometimes
yeah it totally is like they're their um
tail is just creepy the thing is like if
you found a kangaroo
fossils and they were extinct you could
never guess that they balance on their
tails
that kangaroo is being abused it's
terrible yeah they only do this in
america not in australia source i'm from
oh they think this is in america i mean
this is just one person's opinion that
didn't look like they're saying that
it doesn't look like a man yeah that's
animal abuse for sure it looks like asia
that kind of [ __ ] always goes on like
they have all these traveling circuses
and
it is in charge and stuff and they just
like abuse these
these definitely really great critters
bro come at me [ __ ] they are scary i
mean they're really cool
but they really are scary to me what was
i saying is that if we just found their
mo
their skeleton like we do dinosaurs and
they were extinct
you can never possibly guess that they
balance on their tail
oh yeah and they've got a pouch for the
baby they bounce on their tail
and drop kick each other like imagine
how much we don't know about the
dinosaurs like we all assume that we
know so much about them and
we see them animated in movies and video
games and stuff but we have no idea how
they actually
looked like or lived i love the pouch
oops i just closed my document you know
what time it is control what control
shift t
somebody close the whole browser it's
way worse than that
we have uh someone that wants to step up
to the plate all right zach bring him in
his name is niall okay now i like niall
i know a nile yeah and he's on the call
i nile know yeah um so
yeah i'm gonna try and tell my story in
a minute um okay hold on one second let
me get the clock set up here
niall how are you doing today are you
feeling confident
yeah i like i like my chances i i think
i'm going to do good
it's a it's a weird story is it about
poop
it's about pee oh bodily fluid
of course mix it up a little bit mix it
up okay
nile all right well i have the clock
ready so if everybody's good to go
now ela i'm gonna close my eyes if
that's okay with you
niall can i close my eyes yeah this
works for me buddy
all right all right here we go ahead
counting in in three
two one go okay so i've got a pea fetish
i
like being peed on that's just me deal
with it um
my girlfriend would indulge me with that
well just any other regular day
she i asked her hey you want to pee on
me today she says yeah sounds good
uh we get into the shower i lay down in
the shower she squats over me
he starts flowing i've got my head back
eyes closed
loving life having a great odd time and
then she slips
i hear a squeak and then her ass comes
barreling towards my face slams into my
face
uh i hear a massive crunch i think her
ass is just broken like her
her ass bone just broke um and then
next thing is she's looking at me and
her face goes white
i look in the mirror and it turns out my
nose is
sideways horizontal sideways my nose is
broken by her ass bone
i had to go to the hospital and try and
explain my way through that with a
doctor
of how did i just break my [ __ ] nose
and try and get it
that's time oh my god oh my god
why did you um why did you
watch it in a minute you pretty much
nailed it i mean you wrapped it up right
at the minute
pretty much so i have questions
obviously i didn't laugh but i have
questions yeah
no i love questions i i would i would
have liked this to have been a bit more
of a segment but no yeah
so why why not just tell the doctor you
fell or something
why do you have to pull up see so i i
don't drive and my ex-girlfriend
she's my ex now she doesn't drive either
so i had to get my dad to come and take
me to the doctors i told
i told my dad when i drive the reason i
didn't tell the reason i had to
like [ __ ] around with the doctor was
because i thought it was illegal to lie
to a doctor
which i now know it's not weird yeah
that's hilarious so you told the doctor
what happened
yeah i had to i was like is it illegal
to lie to a doctor
i don't know maybe so i was like
okay mr doctor yeah this is what
happened
uh her ass just like [ __ ] slammed
into my face and
my nose is broken i mean it was fully
break it was like
so and then so was she ping so tell me
about
what is it about being peed on that you
like because i was actually it's the
it's it's kind of it's like the warmth
of it like it comes out hot so it's like
you get like a
feeling like it's a hot liquid pouring
on you know where it's coming from like
that's my favorite place
of on on a person so um oh okay that
doesn't sound too weird
are you a submissive um
only in that situation i'd say right
and how did you when did you find out
you were into that
um i think i just was like scrolling
reddit one day and just for no reason at
all
it was on my hot feed and there was just
this woman peeing on her feet
and i was like i was like oh [ __ ] maybe
i would like to be peed on
and so i asked her and she was like yeah
we can try it
on me and yeah just good for you guys
worked for me
and so you would well no yeah not
anymore we broke up about six months ago
so
so if you if you i hope she doesn't hear
this
i'll she'll hear it
and if so if you're dating a girl is the
peeing on like a must or is it like ah
it'd be fun but not a big deal yeah yeah
so more the latter it's like yeah if
you could pee on me that would be nice
but if not then it's is it awkward to
bring it up
at first yeah i've i mean
it for sure yeah it's definitely awkward
to to bring it up
because it's really it's kind of out
there you know you can you can do some
like weird like bdsm
stuff or you can like [ __ ] around with
different kinds of weird sexual things
but i feel like pee is kind of like
it's getting up there in tears it's
getting up but it's not all the way yeah
it sounded like you're well i mean your
ex was down for it i mean how did that
conversation go at least it's not poop
yeah poop is up there like he is yeah
no that's that's that's definitely too
far for me
that just got really turned on
yeah the only the only bad part of being
peed on for me
for sure is the uh the smell so but
you're in the shower right so it's all
good
yeah so you you're in the shower it
cleans up quickly
it's it's you know nice fantastic
nile so do you ever p do you pee on
yourself when you're in the shower does
that turn you on or no
i tried it like once but it just it
wasn't the same
yeah i pee on my feet sometimes because
my parents always [ __ ] lie to me and
they say like
peeing on your feet cures uh athlete's
foot what not that i have athletes
oh you never heard that it's hard no
i've never heard that
athletes never heard that no shower no
my mom used to always tell me when i was
a boy to pee on your feet because it
cures athlete's foot
now i never had athlete's foot but i
always pee on my feet when i'm in the
shower because my mom oh there you go i
mean that's
that's proof what the [ __ ] i swear
that's a thing i swear the p
i think that it's not true so funny but
i have never heard you say that
and yeah there you go i found out
something i think you know
google why would your mom tell you
because my mom's a freak she always
tells me all this crazy [ __ ] like
don't [ __ ] tell your kids crazy [ __ ]
cause they'll carry it around for life
dan are you googling just peeing on foot
athlete's foot i bet you yeah
yeah i got it you know what i'll tell
you this i've never had athlete's face
athlete's face
here some people say urine might cure
athlete's foot because of the urethra
that it the urea that it contains
would have to be a very large amount of
urea more than how much is normally
found in urine
for it to be considered useful to treat
so no it probably does not work but it
sounds like there's a chance it sounds a
bit like chiropractic to me
no no no i thought it worked for
jellyfish things
yeah that's also another [ __ ] yeah
that's [ __ ]
yeah is not a medical use for anything
yeah let's just get that out there right
now
you want to look well it's not it's not
medical
um but it is real fun so give it a try
guys
you never know the jellyfish thing is uh
[ __ ] too yeah look at that a forest
it's a farce it's a forest well don't
tell one don't tell niall's girlfriend
this is all a fart well whoever you're
uh coming up next for you so
i wish you lots of fun and yellow
showers and lots of good peeing times
now
thank you thank you so much thank you
man thank you
take care peace well
we've had a lot of fun here today uh
we've had goofs and gaffs and laughs and
all kinds of things in between eh um
taylor here donated 15 for you to have
pizza for dinner
we found that pizza place you like you
want we did
taylor i [ __ ] love you dude read this
message verbatim
eli this is to buy ethan pizza for
dinner
thanks love y'all bro bro bro bro
bro bro bro brother bro i [ __ ]
love you bro pizza is actually very
nutritious it might be a girl
i think avatar is super tiny i can't
tell you oh it's a girl sorry
apologies regardless so you want to
order well we have to order pizza
taylor did it you heard it here
i love pizza and i love people
right taylor is a feeder yeah
dude can you imagine if i was like
married to someone like taylor i would
be like
so much fatter than i am now it's a good
thing that i'm married to you
in so many ways because
so um tomorrow is our anniversary
and we have no plans for it
that's not true we're having a play date
it's not a celebration of our
anniversary a theodore play that that
sounds really weird when you say we're
having a playdate yeah on our
anniversary
confused oh yeah it's your first
theodore
yeah with another little kid yeah yeah
let's go with our friends
nice i'm buying some wagyu beef
right yeah but that's not which is
apparently 400
what do you mean it's not for us the
wago beef it's not like an anniversary
no it's not it's not to celebrate but
you know it's 450
a pound really i knew it was expensive
but i did not
realize it was that much that's wild
maybe it's 150
jesus [ __ ] maybe it's 115.
all right
wait real quick can you zach can you do
it so it's like play the sound bite
again
you want me to fade it out it should be
like
[Music]
what then like a deep play it repeating
echo
yeah exactly like a deep repeating echo
look if you
yelled that into if you farted into the
grand canyon it would be like
you want the decay longer outcasters
long decay long decay
it's more like a repeating frequency
[Music]
what dan i was just saying we'll
workshop it also uh somebody donated a
hundred dollars for a shout out
for their sister lauren
so shout
[Music]
[Laughter]
happy anniversary wishes no thank you
guys
well the reason i brought it up is
because i think i'm curious what people
think if like after a few years of being
together
does is it normal to still buy gifts to
each other or no
cares what other people do i think it's
both
i think it really both is fine i mean i
think it really just matters
what you decided between each other and
what's the expectation
you know isn't there there's like that
whole um
depending on what year a gift themed on
like a certain
right like and people get really
like there's one for like every year out
to like 50 or something
i've never heard of well there's like 10
i think the first one is 10 or the 10 is
a big milestone so we'll have that in
two years
right 10 year they call it like the
[ __ ] gold
anniversary or whatever [ __ ]
what do you call that
anniversary gifts by a year yeah see
like first paper second anniversary
cotton third
leather fourth fruit or flowers wood
eight you said eight right wood we're on
an eighth pottery or bronze
i'm gonna buy you a pot stupid
what's 10 uh here let me expand it let's
see
10 is tin or aluminum what
kind of [ __ ] what are those
i mean it's saran wrap
this is according to hallmark so i mean
take from that what you will
all right guys we wrapping it up thank
you so much
yet again another wonderful experience
here on after dark
i want to thank enthusiasm our members
who make this episode possible and help
keep our show going
four episodes a week the h3 podcast will
never [ __ ] die
thank you thank you [ __ ]
and thank you to everyone who donated
thank you guys so much we love you
appreciate it thank you to dan
thank you to zach thank you to
e-a-i-e-n thank you to a b
who all work super hard to put this show
together every week we're all working
our butts off here four episodes a week
and uh having a lot of fun hope you guys
are enjoying it too so this is the h3
podcast signing out another week h3
after dark
we'll see you next week monday coming at
you with whitney cummings
that's right it was a good one too yeah
we already shot it it was really fun
great episode and um we don't know what
we're going to do
for thursday next week but we're
thinking about it
because we usually do the content on
that oh and we're going to try something
new
we had an idea i guess maybe we don't
want to say just in case we yeah i'm not
going to say it
okay anyway stay tuned see you guys next
week
all right all right bye-bye
[Music]
you're listening to the hp podcast what
we got on the scene
could it be papa shoe nicer bill delfin
talking front wiper black wife
what you gonna